okay we're going to start and the and
the world is going to hear us
[Applause]
I am Pamela Geller and I am a human
rights
activist we are gathered here today in
honor of dday when the Allied Forces
began to defeat Nazism and the symbolism
should not be
lost not only should the symbolism not
be lost but we're on the corner of
church and
Liberty okay and that's what we're doing
here I want to Welcome All You
Patriots uh infidels Muslims of
conscience Christians Jews
sarrians who are standing up for what's
right Americans
[Applause]
Americans Ground Zero is a war memorial
Ground Zero is a burial ground and the
Moment of Truth has arrived it is
unconscionable to build a shrine to the
very ideology that Inspire the jihadist
attacks at Ground Zero right
[Music]
[Applause]
there we are asking the Imam rou and
Daisy Khan to be
sensitive for mutual respect and mutual
understanding that is demanded of us
every day there is a hair trigger
sensitivity in the Muslim world you can
run the cartoons you can't say Muhammad
you can't this is offensive this is an
offensive mosque to build a shrine an
Islamic flag of
Conquest on the sacred ground the
cherish site of a conquered land this is
historic is this is Islamic history it's
what they do the Saint Sophia in Turkey
Al Goods at the most the holiest Jewish
site in Israel not here this is where we
take a stand we must take a stand we
must say no we have to make it happen
you have to get involved and I want to
introduce my part partner in stop the
islamization of America Robert
Spencer are you tired of being lied
to are you tired of being
smeared every New York politician and
every mainstream media Source on this
story has said this is a story about
tolerance against bigotry and who do you
think they're calling the
bigots the Americans who are standing up
for American values against the most
radically
intolerant and hateful agenda on the
planet what happened
here not long ago
it was a designed
policy
policy of radical
Islam and the policy of terrorist
against
America allowed me if you
forgot it is started with the
Imam a blind
sh Omar abman
when he tried to bring down the World
Trade Center the number one and he
fell when we apprehended him everybody
went to sleep assuming that the Blind
shs and then cor
conspirator they are behind but and
there is no
problems no it wasn't the case because
it is finish they went on and
designed and articulate and they came
and they surprise
us
slaughtering 3,000 of our fellow citizen
here like most Americans I respect the
ideals of multiculturalism diversity and
tolerance but find these principles
unevenly applied in this instance the
Imam of the proposed mosque as he will
tell you himself has led a Muslim
congregation near Ground Zero on Warren
Street for years before and since the
9/11 attacks and he has done so without
opposition from the local community I am
thus irked that several media
commentators would characterize us as
intolerant residents of this
neighborhood
have peacefully coexisted with a mosque
near Ground Zero since the 9/11 attacks
without incence but tolerance and being
a good neighbor requires
reciprocity if the local community has
tolerated a m fisel and his congregation
for so many years he must also tolerate
and respect our sensitivities and show
some more consideration for the
community he lives among
[Applause]
thank
you on May TW on May 25th we attended a
meeting of the community board number
one to hear the plan for a mosque
Community Center Building 600 ft away
from Ground
Zero the first speaker was Miss Margaret
chin and the first thing that Miss chin
said and she's a uh councilwoman New
York City
Council she
thanked she thanked everyone uh in the M
Muslim Community for this great gift and
then said she knew that there are a lot
of people going to speak against it
tonight and we were mostly not motivated
by Prejudice by being bigots and by
being anti-immigration
Mrs chin didn't know what she was
talking about and for most of us we have
never had somebody call us bigots who
never even met
us later on during that meeting and I'm
I think uh Mrs chin had left later on I
told her the story of my own
family I married a daughter of Greek
immigrants one of her sisters married a
cashmir Muslim and I have Muslim
relatives who I love very
much my son married daughter of Korean
immigrants how does she have the nerve
to call me or anybody else a
bigot but what happened was interesting
cuz a number of politicians got up and a
number of them said the same thing
they had the same
Playbook what a shame what a shame is
that the biggest argument they can make
for this new mosque is that we are
bigots if we're against it nothing could
be further from the truth and I say and
I say shame shame shame on all the
politicians and all the people who think
that way
we never said that mosques can't be here
we never said that but not at Ground
Zero not at Ground Zero not at Ground
Zero tolerating intolerance
is not a sign of Honor it's not a sign
of Tolerance it's a sign of gross
negligence it's
weakness and we must never accept the
Triumph of Islam in
America you know I look around and I see
the photograph s of loved ones lost that
appeared in this park when we were here
9 years
ago those families still die a little
bit every single day at the loss of
their loved
ones how the hell can we justify more
madness right here in our own
[Applause]
backyard I'm telling you now now guys
unless we the people stand up to this
Insanity the attacks will continue on
all of us every American must remember
what happened here on this pile not so
long ago and to consider that we have
the
insane
suggestion to build a mosque it is
really a mock a mockery on all of you
every one of
[Applause]
you the attack
continues today and every single one of
you must stand up for America and let
our political leaders what a thought
leaders these are the leaders we send
let's get them out of here and actually
have people that represent
[Applause]
you we celebrate our constitution with a
national holiday both the American and
danish constitutions enshrine the
freedom of
religion however neither of our
constitution nor the Ten Commandments
nor the gospels say you shall be
stupid allowing this mask to be built so
close to the Ground Zero is not only an
insult it is an act of
[Music]
stupidity while everybody has the right
to practice his religion there are
several things to keep in mind here
Islam is a political system as well as a
religion that is well established in
Islamic Theology and law and history it
is Islam as a political and supremacist
system that is at variance with the
United States Constitution we have have
to understand that the distinction has
to be made it has been made in history
in Japan after World War II the
occupying government the American
government in Japan occupying Japan
forbade any state application of Shinto
because it was a militaristic thing but
they allowed the free exercise of Shinto
as a private religious faith if Muslims
were actually to renounce the political
supremacist and hateful aspects of the
religion that deny the freedom of speech
and other rights guaranteed in the US
Constitution then we would have no
trouble whatsoever with their practicing
their religion here and it's in that
context that we support everyone's free
exercise of religion but we're talking
about a political supremacist ideology
that's going to be taught in that
mosque what makes Imam Ru think that
Americans need Memorial two blocks away
from the national N9 andal memorials
which is in construction
already isn't that something that will
separate let's say Muslims from all
others instead of uniting all Americans
against terrorism therefore they do not
want to stay with us confronting
terrorism they just want to demonstrate
something Mr O families of September 11
victims don't buy we don't need a
memorial inside your Cordova House
separating American Muslims from the
rest of America we want everybody who
really respect the Dignity of our loved
ones no matter what religion they were
to come together in here the sacred
place where they were killed not two
blocks away not definitely in your
Muslim
center it's almost 9 years and I'm
hoping that America is watching I'm
hoping that America is remembering
because make no mistake on September
11th it was an act of war and thank the
military that has lost almost 5,000
troops from that day defending us I
don't know what to say to jaar a
memory's memory I want America to
remember what you need to hear you want
to hear that there were people that were
so frightened that they jumped out of
buildings and they exploded on impact
you want to hear that they were
dismembered bodies all over the way you
want to hear that we looked at people
that were got it there's things that we
haven't spoken about we couldn't stop
the people from responding the fire
department that day lost
firefighters they were Unstoppable they
poured into that building
the Port Authority police 37 police
officers
NYPD 23 police officers EMS lost people
civilians were there they helped people
they died helping people America where
are you on this where are you don't you
remember don't you remember what is it
going to take for you to
remember big change
sh big shame that this mask is going to
be here characterizing the existence of
Islamic law in the United
States big shame for building this mask
big shame for Obama big shame for all
the leaders and the politician in the
state of New York
sh sh shame on them of our family
doesn't have a grave even people who has
a grave on a cemetery they get just
small piece of body from mother from
father from Sun rest of the body it's
Ash and blood and everything on the
ground Zer this is the grave this is the
FAL place and I don't want to say what
all Muslim is terrorist of course not
but people 19 people who kill
3,000 American they was Muslim and we
don't want mask on a ground zero they
can build any place but not Ground Zero
I want you to see
this this is part of the plane this is
part of the plane that went into the
trade that went into the Trade Centers
that's in the Burlington Coat
Factory this is a war memorial this is
this has the blood of our American
Brothers on it and I say that we design
at the Burlington war memorial that it's
a Historic Landmark like Gettysburg like
Pearl
Harbor and we are going to sue the US
government to get a designation of war
memorial
status what's happening my uh my home is
within two blocks of the mosque that
train the people those evil cowardly
bastards who flew those planes into this
Tower they train them in false Church
Virginia it is the only mosque which
almost has more FBI agents than it has
Muslims we need your help we need your
help throughout
America June 6th 1944
dday my father-in-law was a 19-year-old
kid an Italian kid from Hell's Kitchen
he was drafted and he landed at
Normandy I was always so in awe that I
knew somebody who had been
there his
generation helped save Europe from a
tyranny that had murdered Millions not
just because they were of the wrong
Faith but because they believed in the
freedom of the
individual just like September
11th
2001 3,000 Americans were murdered not
just because they were of the wrong
Faith but because they believed in the
freedom of the
individual not Sharia
law America is a free country our
constitution guarantees religious
freedom individual rights but we are
allowing in the name of Tolerance people
who subscribe to the totalitarian rigid
reductionist and host is and DC Paradigm
to come here to exploit our freedom and
in the name of Freedom construct a MOS
to preach hatred the insult of those who
die
here the last word of the
terrorists it was Allah abbar when they
come to kill us and they want to build
the m to say Allah but every single
minute here we say
no
[Applause]
no our
goal is to preserve the unique and
exceptional character of this nation we
are here because we will not allow this
sacred ground to be contaminated with
totality Arian
logic not here not
now because to allow this to go forward
would be an insult to those who died
here to the families of those who perish
here to the heroes that risk their lives
to save those slaughtered
here not here not now
[Applause]
because to do so will merely reopen an
indelible scar seared on this sacred
plot of soil the wounds have not healed
Imam and we cannot soon forget the
hatred that spawn this assault on our
sensibilities is still taught in too
many of your m and inscribed on too many
of your prayer
rugs where are the Muslim mothers and
why aren't they denouncing the fact that
their little children are blowing up
their own
people killing them blowing them up and
taking our sons and daughters down with
them somebody needs to call them out
[Applause]
we are
tolerant but the
idea of building a mosque out of sight
of such
historical and tragic import to our
country is anatha to
us what we have to say in a loud voice
is
no no no
no no how could the mayor of New York
not step in and do something when he
doesn't even know who is paying for this
mosque
four
4.85 million to buy a building in cash a
100 million to rebuild it in
cash I suspect that the same Blood
Stained hands that supported the
terrorists on September 11th they are
the people and it's up to Mayor to find
[Applause]
out we are here to stand for America to
stand for the people we lost on that day
in an act of War by the same ideology
that will be taught in that mosque make
no mistake they say it will be different
but they will be reading the same Quran
and teaching the same Islamic law that
led those 19 hijackers to destroy the
World Trade Center and murder 3,000
Americans they will come to pay their
pilgrimage right here in New York at the
Mosk our 3,000
fellow Americans who were killed on
911 are looking down on
us and they are saying we don't want to
hear Allah abbar
anymore the value of AAS here as a tool
of islamist propaganda cannot be
underestimated
from my personal experience living with
and among Muslims in Asia I dispute the
idea that this mosque will stand as a
symbol of interfaith dialogue or
multiculturalism in most of the Muslim
World rather it will most likely appear
to many Muslims as a monument of
jihadist Victory and a symbol of
American
weakness this in turn will fuel the
Recruitment and legitimize the agenda of
islamists throughout the world and this
is not in our best interest As Americans
if we were at the community board
meeting when they approved this mosque
to1 and they said the mosque leaders say
that they believe in tolerance and so
okay
are you tired of being treated like a
they say they believe in tolerance
and so that's the end of the story as
far as the mainstream media and the
mayor of New York and everybody else is
concerned except for everybody with a
grain of sense and eyes in our head the
Imam fisel Abdul
is on record in favor of bringing
Islamic law Sharia to the United
[Applause]
States read his book read his book he
says there should be restrictions on the
freedom of speech in the United
States it's in there but nobody I bet
the mayor hasn't read it the community
board hasn't read it and Imam F Abdul R
said he believed in
tolerance Mr R true Americans don't need
that Memorial in the Cordova House true
Americans don't need the relationship
between us and the Muslim World built on
disrespect to those who were killed here
on 911 and true Americans do not need
your mask at the filment of the memory
of September 11
victims what are we going to say to
those who want to take away our freedom
and democracy who want to use our
American freedom to kill American
democracy we want to say to them
no no
again no and now they have an audacity
to build the M Church in our face
we saying
no
no no matter
what no
way this is an
insult to
America and this is an insult to New
Yorkers there was a 14
story P building of rubble that smoked
until December of
2001 on September 12th we all came
together people from all over this
country people from other countries came
together to help us we had to turn
people away we couldn't even have the
room for The
Rescuers 14 stories of rubble but did
that stop us that didn't stop us that
doesn't stop Americans they told us it
would take over a year over a year to
clear that but now we did it within 9
months construction
workers the the Red
Cross the excuse me on these flags that
I hold on my hand the American flag and
the honor flag the honor flag contains
two
1,996 names then lost their lives on
that particular day but this flag was
revised from
2006 since then many more people have
died counting some of the people been Li
last month five of them including police
officers and
firemen one that died before yesterday a
policeman 40 years years old that die of
cancer on
consequence of the pollution or the or
the dust that was here on those
particular
months I sered here during the recovery
and also a Survivor I was underneath the
South Tower when the tower collapsed and
I'm here Alive by the power of God and
that caused me pain to know that alive
and many of my friends and cers
die I come here to per homish to a name
his name was Joseph C Zaki and he worked
for counter fish Gerald on the 104th
floor I have never had the honor to talk
to his wife in person I spoke to her
over the phone the first December of
2001 I they know that they had two
wonderful children and that he was a
wonderful man like many of our follow
Americas that died that
day are we here today because we
opposing the Muslims to build mosque no
we are not but we opposing the building
of the most con sacred ground we don't
want them here around the World Trade
Center side do we
[Applause]
no we don't want this MKS to be built
around here the World Trade Center for a
particular reason because he will be
very disrespectful to us to the families
that lost their relatives their sons
brothers childr and
families I talk to you from my heart to
all of you that have
children nine years have gone by by and
as the years go by I see that we as
Americans we are tending to forget what
happened here that day and we forgot how
to be United I do remember that day when
I was working on the bragget Brigade I
do remember that day when I was under
the rubble looking for our Lov ones and
hoping that I was to find somebody alive
it was not able
and I should be thankful to God for my
life and I am but I plead to you never
forget what happened here and do hope
that this
911 many of us Americans come here and
remember what happened here teach you
children that they were so young to
understand what really happened
particularly the ones that are seven
they do not know what happened here the
ones are 12 they do not know in reality
many of them what happened
here so I plead to you with the bottom
of my heart remember that camerie that
we used to have on the 9/11 there were
not distinctions of
color no race no
status we are all brothers and sisters
and childrens of God and I'm going to
repeat once more we are not against to
building their MOS just don't building
around
here God Bless America God bless our
soldiers and foreign lands defending our
freedom God Bless America and God bless
us all